[Music]
joining me today is a sex researcher a
neuroscientist and co-host of the wrong
speak podcast dr. Deborah so welcome to
the Rubin report hi I am glad to have
you here finally I'm so happy to be here
all right we got a lot to talk about I
thought the best way to start this thing
I don't like to look at my notes upfront
but you had a line on your patreon page
that I thought summed up the whole damn
thing pretty perfectly your patreon bio
says creating journalism that defends
science and free speech you've come to
the right show all right I think so yeah
okay should we talk about sex first
should we just start with sex and then
cuz it's all gonna it all bleeds into
one thing definitely yeah okay you
started as a neuroscientist
but you were sort of more attracted for
a lack of a better word to studying sex
tell me about that yeah so I mean I
decided to go back to school and do my
PhD in neuroscience and along the way I
had the chance to do a placement in
psychology so I'd never heard of sex
research before I had no idea what it
was but it was so fascinating to me and
I thought it's crazy that we have the
technology to look at people's brains
and look at sexual arousal in the brain
and it tells us so much about what it
means to be human so from from there I
was hooked I loved it my PhD was in
using brain imaging to look at
paraphilias which are a typical sexual
interest and hyper sexuality in men and
I love research I always will but I made
the decision to leave academia and work
full-time as a journalist now because
the climate had changed so much even
between when I started my PhD and when
it when I finished yeah and that's why
the stuff that you're talking about
really is a nexus of everything that I'm
doing here because now you're on the
journalist side but it's because of the
hostility that you were facing on the
academic side so what worried what is it
that you were unearthing or studying
that was so triggering to people HM well
within psychology you can't really study
anything that isn't triggering it's
across the board someone's gonna get mad
at you no matter what but even though
you're really looking at facts you're
look you're you're looking to find
yeah exactly and even with brain imaging
I mean that's that's definitely it's a
growing feel the technology is
legitimate but no matter what I think
because sex is still considered very
taboo people will either project their
own ideas and beliefs and values onto it
or they just don't see the value and
they think why is the government funding
this I feel really lucky being in Canada
we do have a pretty amazing scene in
terms of sex research and my colleagues
do manage to get funding so I think
that's excellent but my decision to
leave academia in the last two years I
had noticed things were starting to go a
bit weird and in terms of the climate
and in terms of mainstream media I was
seeing piece after piece about
transgender kids and how young children
were socially transitioning getting on
blockers pubertal blockers and the media
is basically saying this is the greatest
thing this is something that we should
rejoice about that these kids are so
much better off after but from a
scientific perspective the research
actually shows that the majority of kids
who are gender dysphoria grow their
feelings they're more likely to grow up
to be gay in adulthood not transgender
and so it makes sense for them to wait
not for them to socially transition at a
young age so I wanted to write a
mainstream piece about this and there's
been a very long-standing history
between trans activists and sex
researchers a very ugly history of
activists going after sex researchers if
they don't like what some one study says
or what they say publicly so I thought
about it for a long time I wrote the
piece and I sat on it probably for about
six months and I wasn't sure if I wanted
to put it out I asked a bunch of my
colleagues and mentors and they all said
you know what the science is solid but
you know you know what's gonna happen if
you do put this out and at the time I
wanted to stay in academia and I said
should I wait till I get tenure and
everyone told me even if you have tenure
nowadays it's not going to protect you
you can still lose your job so I decided
eventually I couldn't stay quiet and I
thought I'm not going to stay in an
environment where I can't speak the
truth and I can't even pursue questions
that are meaningful anymore because I
have to worry about who's gonna get mad
and then I'm gonna lose my money and my
funding and I'm gonna lose my job so
that piece went out it's called white
transgender kids show a way to
transition and
and I haven't looked back since yeah so
I reread I've read the piece before but
I reread it this morning thank you I got
here and there's a lot here so how much
of this is just blade is just blatantly
a misunderstanding of science like I
think there's partly that you have a
misunderstanding of science and then you
just have activists who just want you to
bow to them all the time are you able to
sort of quantify how much of the
backlash is each I think should be
charitable I try to look at the other
side and give them you know credit and
try to you know think that they have
good intentions
maybe people I mean it's pretty
consistent all 11 studies ever done on
the topic of desist in so this
phenomenon I talked about where kids
grow out of their feelings of gender
dysphoria all of them say the same thing
so the final statistic is about 60 to 90
percent so this is the vast majority of
kids you can't really question those
data so I think what it could be is
people I mean trans people have a
history of having you do of medical
gatekeeping of people telling them they
don't really what they feel isn't real
I do think gender dysphoria is a real
phenomenon and I do think we should have
empathy for people who are suffering so
I think it could be coming from that of
that place of well we don't want people
saying that this isn't a legitimate
thing or that trans people should be
forced to not feel the way they do but
in terms of you know these children we
should be thinking about the best
outcome so it doesn't make sense for
them to transition if that's not
actually going to help them in the long
term I try to give people the benefit
the doubt but I do think the activists
they on some level I think they know
that they can bully sex researchers
because of that history they know that
there's only so much an academic can do
and they've won a couple battles so I
think that's part of it as well
how shocking was it to you when you were
discussing this with colleagues that
they were kind of hinting you may want
to wait on this thing I mean did you
think that you'd be in that situation
and I'm wondering did any of them sit on
some other things because they were
afraid to hmm it was eye-opening
yeah but I kind of knew one
one I guess instance I can talk about is
one colleague Michael Bailey at
Northwestern University he wrote a book
that upset transgender activists and
they went off after him ruthlessly I
mean they really tried to destroy his
life and thankfully you know he's he's
still considered one of the foremost
experts in psychology internationally
but I would say that you know I've
written about him previously I think
he's kind of been the poster boys to why
people are really terrified to say
anything that goes against the trans
narrative yeah so I think you've already
hinted at this and I know your work
otherwise but so you have no issue with
trans people as people just to be clear
this is purely about the science related
to transitioning and hormone blockers
and things of that nature of a certain
age where they're doing it as young as I
think you're right about 14 right oh
younger than that now well yeah I mean
if there's parental consent definitely
and I have to say for transgender adults
and I say even kids who reach puberty
and still feel that way I think
transitioning is is totally up to you if
that's what the path you decide to go
then power to you I don't think there's
any ones penny it's anyone's business to
tell you what to do at that point so a
lot of their basic parameters related to
age then well there are in terms of I
don't work with children I don't do
clinical work anymore but in terms of
the research literature usually
clinicians will wait until puberty and
see how the child feels at that time
when the body starts changing when they
start having crushes on their peers and
that kind of thing and the research does
show that when kids start to you know
have crushes and start dating and that
can play a role in terms of how they
feel about their bodies and whether they
do outgrow it but just at that point
your whole body is in flux your mental
states and flux your physical states and
flux and as you said what did you say a
percentage on that of how many of them
turn out to just they generate so yeah
so they so sixty to ninety percent of
the the children undergoing these
feelings turn out to be gay and then I
assume the ones that don't transition
probably most of them end up being okay
with being gay I would imagine
roughly yeah and I would say even I grew
up in the gay community I have a lot of
gay male friends and they've said to me
when I was young I told my parents all
the time
hated being a boy and I wanted to be a
girl and I am a girl and why can't I
become a girl and now as a gay man I'm
so comfortable I'm so happy and they say
to me you know I'm kind of glad I'm not
growing up in this time because I think
I probably would have transitioned yeah
well that's why the the external
pressure seems so crazy to me because
you just don't know at that at that age
and even if you do know waiting a little
bit isn't gonna for the science to flesh
out it's not that's not gonna kill you
it's just hard talking about this even
you know yeah I mean the thing is what
people also aren't talking about is that
for these kids so in some cases the
parents don't want a gay child and this
is what upsets me the most so if you
have a little boy who's very feminine
he's likely gonna grow up to be a gay
man but if you take that same Lavoie and
allow him to transition to female when
he grows up he's gonna appear to be a
straight woman and so these parents are
being lauded as progressive when really
they're homophobic God how perverse that
is that's interesting what you just said
about a certain amount of gay men that
grow up you know they wanted to be or
felt more like a girl or whatever and
that eventually grow out and we were
okay
because I never felt that like I played
sports and I played video games and
transformers all all the things that my
friends did I never felt like I was a
girl or more effeminate people always
say to me I don't seem gay I'm always
like I don't know what that you know I
didn't mean like I'm married to a guy
yeah I mean that's pretty gay but I
never had that but that's that's sort of
just interesting about the psychology Oh
gay people in general there are gay
people that grow up feeling very
effeminate or gay men that grow up not
feeling that way and I'm sure there's
women that grow up feeling very butch or
whatever and there's women that grow up
that are you know lipstick lesbians yeah
and the whole thing have you done any
research on it on any of that in terms
of my research no but in terms of what
studies have shown it is about hormone
levels in utero
so testosterone if you are exposed to
higher levels of testosterone in utero
you're more likely to be male typical in
masculine when you're born so whether
you're male or female so most boys are
exposed to high levels of testosterone
so that explains when they're born why
they are interested in male typical toys
and activities so for gay men they were
likely exposed to lower levels of
testosterone which is why
they're more feminine and the same with
with girls if they're exposed to higher
levels of testosterone they're more
likely to be masculine and lesbian right
even though there's obvious outliers
this is on average on average anna is is
there danger in talking about that
because I would imagine that the certain
amount of people in the gay community
that would want you to never go down
that road because then you could end up
in a place where oh we would be able to
prevent people from being hey ultimately
if we can really figure out the science
behind all this definitely and I mean as
a straight woman I have to say I even
iron right now feel like maybe I
shouldn't be saying these things because
I'm not gay I can't speak for the a
community but as a former sex researcher
I am very much a proponent of I'd rather
you speak researcher that a gay person
or a straight person or anything else I
mean this this is the problem though
you're you know to be like you're an
expert in this and it's like even for
you who's so brave on all of these
issues it gets weird to talk about it
even for me I just it's like a little
weird to talk about you feel like a
traitor no I I am what I am and that's
all that I am that's it but like I know
that just even talking about this just
gets people crazy and I know what our
what our Twitter feeds are gonna look
like yeah you get ready so I mean it's
crazy because even my colleagues who
have the best intentions they're doing
this research because they just want to
understand why are people the way they
are it's not there are no nefarious
intentions there but people are so quick
to jump on I mean there was earlier this
year that there was a study about using
AI to be able to detect whether someone
is gay by looking at their face and so
again studies have shown that on average
you can see differences between straight
and gay people both men and women in
terms of facial features and so
everyone's freaking out about this study
and I'm thinking why aren't we saying
this is amazing that we are able to know
this and I mean I think I've really good
gaydar I've always thought I have and
now I think great like there's actually
some quantitative data to suggest that
I'm not just making things up right and
they're also they always say well gay
guys have gaydar there's something else
that maybe you can see or whatever it is
or though they're I don't know the
people say it anymore but he was just a
gay face like there was just something
about the facial features sometime
of gay men maybe they were a little
softer or whatever it is I don't even
know what it is but like people were
talking about that in the gay community
then it comes out through some sort of
science lens and it's like ooh we better
watch out for that and the thing is then
researchers see that and say well I
don't want to go through that so then
they don't want to touch that topic so
now there's they're eventually going to
be only like two different things you
can probably study unless you know that
what your findings what you're going to
find is going to be politically
acceptable in which case you shouldn't
be doing the research because that means
you're not actually doing science yeah
what do you think it is about you that
makes you brave enough to do this sort
of thing because I've had a couple other
people we're going to talk about James
the more in a little bit cuz you've also
written about him and and why the whole
thing about diversity and all that but
I've had a bunch of outliers in these
communities on the show and I'm always
curious what it is about the specific
people that make them sort of put it out
there and go I'm gonna do it whether you
like it or not it's probably my
personality yeah I mean I just generally
don't really care what people think
about me and I'm pretty stubborn and I
I'm very I feel very strongly about sex
research being taken seriously and my
decision to have gone and gone into that
field you deal with a lot of stigma as I
mentioned earlier you deal with it on
both sides you know and when you make
the decision to go into the field
suddenly when people know what you do
they will judge you on a personal level
so I think that was part of it you know
I grew a very thick skin from saying I'm
gonna do what I find interesting people
can assume whatever they want about me
and that I think that just translated
into now what I do as a science
journalist but this I would say to and
I'm sure you probably went through a
similar experience once you speak out it
becomes much easier and I find I can't I
can't stay quiet now and I find the
people that are gonna you know turn
their backs on you let them because you
don't need them in your life yeah once
you start you just you can't stop
actually yeah if it's built into you you
just can't stop so one of the things I
think is really interesting is how you
know there's there's such a movement
always to say that gay people are born
this way right Lady Gaga even wrote a
song about war in this way party Gaga
yeah and yet at the same time if I know
for a fact like I have a friend who for
many years was my lesbian friend
one good lesbian friend and she was you
know datin girls all the time and all
that then about three years ago we were
sitting there and she told me that she
met a guy and now she's been with this
guy for about three or four years and
they're getting married and she
identifies basically as bisexual now but
she's only she's exclusively been with a
guy for about four years but what I find
interesting about it is that her lesbian
friends have basically all turned on her
and this is supposed to be that these
are supposed to be the people of
tolerance and we should accept your
sexuality and all that but when it goes
the other way suddenly it becomes this
other thing have you have you seen that
before I suspect you hey I can imagine
that I'm guessing they probably think
that she sold out they think she's a
sellout
yeah yeah you're taking the easy road or
something like that like every insane
cliche and I know her to be completely
authentic and real how does how has she
dealt with it I'm curious it's been well
it's woken her up in a zillion other
ways so for a lot of the other things
that that we talked about about free
speech and politics and freedom and all
that she started to wake up to all of
that she was a huge lefty progressive
and now she's basically a libertarian
because she saw that authoritarian thing
why do you guys want to control me yeah
the second I think differently you guys
want to control me yeah so now she's
like the locust of all of my friends so
to speak that's the thing I think all of
us are eventually gonna have a moment
like that where you realize what you
thought was the truth is not the truth
and there there's so many other things
it's like falling down that rabbit hole
in real and you start to question
everything then and it's really
liberating but you know in terms of
sexuality that's I mean that's very
common women female sexuality is much
more fluid than men so men tend to be
very category specific if you're into
women you really like women and you're
not two guys if you're into guys -
really guys not women and then women
tend to be a little bit more flexible
it's like you find you know there are
mostly straight married men that on the
DL are sleeping with other guys but I'm
pretty sure there aren't many gay men
that are in relationships are married
that are sneaking out and sleeping with
women know on the DL have you ever seen
one of those in your research okay
there's gotta be right
you know I think the first case I think
is probably closeted gays and then the
second case I have to think about that
right but you're a closeted gay well I
guess you might be sleeping yeah I mean
I did it like I slept with women as sort
of like an overcompensation or I was
trying it's not even over compensation I
was really trying I just thought I
should try and I tried and you know
eventually I tried no more yeah I think
also for gay men when you come out it's
such a big thing and I think to make
that decision to come out is really
committing to this as much as you know
we don't like identity labels it is an
identity label so I would see it as
being less common for someone who's gay
to be sleeping with women on the side
because he would have likely just stayed
in that camp right that would be my
guess
yes okay so you mentioned that you you
study a lot of this related to the brain
how a lot of this is sort of built into
us and you study this across sort as
fetishes the right word paraphilias yeah
yeah fetish is a specific paraphilia but
across the board basically kinky people
yeah it's a way what's the definition of
paraphilia
unusual sexual interests and has that
different than fetish well fetish is a
specific object or body part that you
have a preference for got it so so let's
talk about a couple of those okay there
are a lot of them so I always I tell
people this and no one ever believes me
but I'm actually very very traditional
vanilla and not kinky but I love it
gonna ask you all that at the end about
yourself pretty much but okay yeah but I
mean I I find it super fascinating and I
guess that's my way of living
vicariously you know so in terms of
different paraphilias I mean there's
voyeurism soap you know known as peeping
tom exhibitionism so people like to
expose themselves sadism and masochism
which are different from BDSM so BDSM is
consensual masochism and sadism so
masochism being wanting wanting to be
humiliated sadism is one just your
partner being humiliated BDSM is very
much about consent so it's not true
masochism or sadism because partners
will negotiate beforehand and not do
anything outside
of particular boundaries and that kind
of thing what else is there
FRA tourism so it's when people like to
rub up against unsuspecting people there
tons I could go on forever mm-hmm yeah
and so how are these all connected to
the same parts of the brain is it the
same men mechanism that's working and
the fetish itself is just manifested in
a different targets yeah so with my
research when I was still a researcher I
found that for men who are kinky when
they look at kinky pornography the same
brain network activates as when non
kinky people are looking at regular or
vanilla pornography so it suggests that
paraphilia is maybe akin to a sexual
orientation so that's not to say that's
the same as being gay but it's the same
idea conceptually that it's someone's
preference it can't be changed and it's
with them from from very early on yeah
how does the internet play into all this
because I know you've you've written
about porn addiction and yeah things
like that where now all of this stuff is
so accessible where obviously I've been
15 20 years ago it's a lot more looking
for it yeah I think people are probably
able to test out different things and go
searching for things out of curiosity
but if you really like something I don't
think it's because you happen to find it
on the internet and with porn addiction
in particular there's no research to
suggest that it's a real thing that
excessive porn viewing is akin to an
addiction usually if you talk to someone
with problems with porn
across the board it's there's always
some other reason why either they're
anxious they like to procrastinate or
they don't like to procrastinate but
they use it as a way of procrastinating
and avoiding other things it's not that
they're actually addicted to pornography
right so when you hear those that people
will say well you're getting that
dopamine yeah isn't that partly what
being addicted you wouldn't you become
addicted to that well my understanding
the term addiction slightly incorrectly
that's true but dopamine is released
during the number of different things if
you eat a nice piece of food that you
like dopamine is released if you see a
nice picture dopamine stress I mean it's
reward but it's responsible for a lot of
different things so I think that's one
case of I mean I do have some issue with
science journalists watering things down
and liking to take one finding or one
study and kind of you know representing
it or mister
presenting it so it's not really an
accurate take on it but I understand why
people think that because dopamine has
been seen as the the addiction
neurotransmitter and you see so much
about porn addiction sex addiction I
would say probably a year ago it was
everywhere everyone was talking about
porn addiction and sex addiction even
though there again there's no legitimate
research to suggest either of those
things are real hmm so when you've
studied all of these things what are
what are you finding out about the brain
as a neuroscientist and can anything be
done for any of these things if somebody
was are taking in these things and
either didn't want to or at least wanted
to understand it or whatever else the
biggest thing I would say is find a
partner who accepts you for who you are
because whatever you're into especially
for men it's not going to change and so
the difference between someone who has
meaning women's kinks or whatever will
change with time where a man would be
less than quite I do yeah the same with
you know in the same way with the sexual
orientation women tend to be more
flexible with their sexual preferences
so if they're kinky they might be really
kinky with one partner or if they have a
partner who's very kinky they might be
into whatever he's into if it's a
straight couple
but then if she's with someone who's
less kinky might not be as much of a
problem whereas if it's a man who's
really into something if his partner's
not into it he's always going to be into
it he's just gonna have to hide it yeah
have you heard of this phrase lesbian
bed death um oh I'm all over the place
I'm just going into the fall to come up
with yeah by have you heard this phrase
before it means that there's no sex
after a certain amount of time yeah that
lesbians it sort of burns very hot for
that early period and then the u-haul
shows up in a joke and then just like
the desire for sex just disappears just
lots of cuddling yeah yeah I have heard
of that well men on average do tend to
have a higher sex drive so I could see
if you're in a relationship where it's
two women how this you know their sex
drive might be a bit lower not sure what
else like if not anything else all right
what what are you really thinking about
right now right
in general what are the the topics that
are really on your mind related to all
this my concern number one is probably
seeing how gender is being warped to
facilitate particular political agendas
as you mentioned James two more and
seeing how that whole thing unfolded
last summer okay so let's talk about
could you wrote a piece on it I remember
the piece coming out I did yeah so I
remember when that news first broke that
this sexist memo was going around and I
read it and I thought okay this is not
sexist and then I saw the statement from
Google that he was perpetuating gender
stereotypes and I thought oh no and so I
wrote that column for The Globe and Mail
to speak to the science and say you know
what the science that James cited was
absolutely 100% legitimate and there
shouldn't be anything wrong with saying
that and if you actually read his memo
you'll see that he's not a misogynist
and we actually so the podcast that I
co-host with Jonathan Kaye called wrong
speak we actually interviewed him for
our first episode and if you listen to
him speak you can see I mean he's very
much for equality between the sexes he
says that if men and women don't talk to
each other that's gonna harm both of us
but it was much easier for them to paint
him as a misogynist and as an alt right
figure because I guess you know there's
nothing else going on the news did you
feel that the article or at least when
James was able to get out there and say
what he thought whether he did it here
or on Rogan or a series of other
podcasts did you feel that that was able
to break through to some of the people
that it needed to break through to like
I know it gets to the masses right it
gets to the people who appreciate maybe
what happens in here or on Rogan or
things like that but for any of the
people that really need to hear it the
ones that are at Google or the ones that
are setting the diversity agenda at
schools and all that is there any sign
that any of this push back against it
has taken root no I think it's gone
worse if anything honestly which is
terrible I think they are so set in that
mindset that you really can't you can't
say anything I think reasonable people
if you talk to them I was surprised
actually at that time because a lot of
people that I knew that were really
intelligent really rational had bought
into this narrative that he was a sexist
person who said that
women are biologically inferior and are
not capable of engineering or working in
tech and I said well why would you think
that did you read the memo and most
people had no idea but then because
left-wing media was so adamant about
this message people just assumed well
they're not gonna lie
why would they lie and you know we are
in this industry so of course we know
but I think most people just take a face
value they're busy they have their jobs
and so they see a headline or they see
an interview they just think well I like
a mainstream interview they think well
they wouldn't be saying these things if
there wasn't some truth to them but no
they're blatantly lying they're
blatantly lying has all of this and
being part of this and now you know
being very public about your opinions
has this changed your politics at all I
find that it consistently has changed
people's politics usually it ships
people to more of what I would say is a
classical liberal position but what a
libertarian just more of a less
government position as you want because
that's where I think at the moment the
most freedom lays yeah I would agree
with that and especially the idea of the
government I used I used to be
definitely more left much much more left
I would still call myself a liberal but
definitely now that I see because I used
to think was good for the government to
come in and help people and to kind of
set the tone but now now I'm seeing
things that are not hate speech or being
considered hate speech and genuine facts
were not allowed to say them anymore so
I'm much more skeptical now of
government intervention of policies
dictating what people can and cannot do
or say so I would say I have moved more
to the right but I would still call
myself a liberal and I mean the fact
that I write about sex research for a
living is pretty left yeah you're my
kinda liberal so you're good to go here
[Music]